[Música]
se cumplen seis meses del inicio de la
invasión rusa a ucrania mientras que sí
y eeuu advierten que el ejército de
vladimir putin planea recrudecer su
ofensiva a pesar de 190 días de
sanciones económicas para hacerlo
retroceder para seguir apoyando al
pueblo ucraniano washington dará 3 mil
millones de dólares más en ayudas
eeuu ha admitido que puede hacer una
mejor labor en su lucha contra las
drogas el gobierno de joe biden espera
renovar su cooperación con colombia
después de que el presidente de gustavo
petro calificará de obsoletos en las
políticas actuales analizamos
y los demócratas de florida eligieron a
charlie crist o para enfrentar al actual
gobernador o ron de santis en las
elecciones de noviembre este estado
tradicionalmente republicano podría irse
al lado demócrata en rechazo a las
decisiones como la prohibición del
aborto y la ley conocida como no digas
gay tenemos información desde miami
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí están las noticias de
france 24 este 24 de agosto se cumplen
seis meses de la invasión rusa a ucrania
medio año en el que la comunidad
internacional no ha logrado hacer
retroceder a rusia pese a las múltiples
sanciones económicas y bloqueos que ha
impuesto para asfixiar al presidente
vladimir putin y sus aliados el recuento
en el informe de mar y aclara calle
intentar asfixiar económicamente a rusia
esa ha sido la principal respuesta de
occidente por la guerra el primer golpe
llevó a las pocas horas de que comenzó
la invasión a ucrania cuando el consejo
europeo congeló los activos y prohibió
las visas del primer grupo de personas
cercanas al kremlin estados unidos
prohibió la venta de insumos
tecnológicos a rusia la siguiente
sanciones fueron directamente contra el
presidente vladimir putin y su canciller
sérguei lávrov fauna encantado de ser
alcalde después de una conversación
telefónica entre el presidente y bailén
y la presidenta de la comisión europea
von der leyen y en consonancia con la
decisión de nuestros aliados europeos
eeuu y unir a ellos para sancionar al
presidente putin y al ministro de
relaciones exteriores larroque y a
miembros del equipo de seguridad
nacional rusa
si tan solo la unión europea ha
sancionado a un centenar de entidades y
a más de 1200 personas incluidas putin y
lávrov
351 parlamentarios y más de 30 oligarcas
además el transporte también se ha
limitado el bloque restringió sus vías
terrestres su espacio aéreo y sus
puertos para los rusos con contadas
excepciones para quienes llevan
materiales
y corto la difusión de cinco medios
estatales incluyendo sputnik bruselas y
washington también prohibieron la
importación de materias primas como el
oro y el hierro y al corazón de la
economía lo atacaron limitando las
transacciones con el banco ruso central
el golpe más fuerte fue la exclusión del
sistema swift lo que desconectó los
bancos rusos del sistema financiero
internacional ya están sacando
beneficios
el primer ministro y yo discutimos el
tema teniendo en cuenta que las
sanciones que la comunidad occidental o
como yo la llamo el imperio de mentiras
está intentando implementar en contra de
nuestro país 3
eeuu fue un paso más allá y cortó el gas
natural una movida que europa aún está
lejos de hacer por su alta dependencia
putin comenzó a hablar de países no
amistosos ya ellos les puso una nueva
cláusula pagar en rublos todo el gas que
comprarán de rusia una medida por la que
ya se ha acortado el suministro de
naciones europeas como polonia bulgaria
y finlandia además moscú también
prohibió la entrada a su territorio a
cientos de personas de todo el mundo
incluyendo a bailén parlamentarios
británicos japoneses entre otros luego
llegó la decisión más difícil para la
unión europea cortar el crudo la
decisión se tomó con fuertes divisiones
hungría república checa y eslovaquia
lograron que no se frenará su
importación por oleoductos dada su alta
dependencia los europeos acusaron a
rusia de usar la energía como un arma de
guerra
en general que decirlo la situación está
empeorando en la medida en que los
anuncios sobre el uso de gas y petróleo
como armas ahora se están haciendo
realidad en varios lugares
stein jr
en medio de la guerra 300 compañías ya
salieron de rusia y cerca de 700
redujeron considerablemente sus
operaciones entre ellas están adidas
nike disney netflix spotify starbucks la
petrolera shell cocacola entre otras los
resultados de las múltiples presiones
económicas son un pib ruso que podría
caer un 11,2 por ciento este año según
la proyección del banco mundial y una
inflación en la mayoría de los países
occidentales que ha subido los precios a
niveles históricos el director de la
oficina de política nacional de control
de drogas de la casa blanca de rahul
gupta habló desde bogotá la capital
colombiana y reconoció que el gobierno
estadounidense podría hacerlo mejor en
la lucha contra los estupefacientes
además aceptó que las políticas en la
materia marginalizado poblaciones y
aseguró que espera poder operar con
colombia en una nueva era bajo el
gobierno de la izquierdista gustavo
petro vamos al análisis con jorge
restrepo profesor de la universidad
javeriana de colombia y director del
centro de recursos o para el análisis de
conflictos
jorge gracias y gustavo petro dijo la
semana pasada que no deberían ser
criminalizados los campesinos ni los
consumidores y que el enfoque debe
cambiar porque eeuu estas cediendo entre
las apreciaciones del mandatario
bueno porque la política como se ha
venido aplicando hasta ahora ha sido
tremendamente efectiva no reduce ni el
tráfico ni la producción de drogas y
tampoco tienen efectos sobre el precio
de manera que eso tiene que cambiar
está mucho más cerca de la legalización
yo diría que sí pero de uno de una
legalización total sino de una
legalización parcial para algunas drogas
aquellas que tal vez sean menos dañinas
y aquellas que tengan menos componentes
de actividad como el cannabis pero sin
lugar a dudas estamos más cerca de des
en términos globales
y finalmente gusta dijo que esta nueva
era busca poner el problema de las
drogas como un asunto de salud
sociosanitario pero sin soltar el
enfoque militarista del que colombia ha
sido laboratorio puede realmente cambiar
el enfoque
yo creo que puede cambiar sobre todo
para que se concentre la acción militar
policía judicial en poblaciones
diferentes por ejemplo la de los
campesinos cultivadores de cultivos de
uso ilícito como la hoja de coca
luego como incluso la marihuana que se
utilizan para la fabricación de estas
drogas pero no creo que pueda llegar a
cambiar están tanto no se convierta esto
en una iniciativa que tenga futuro en
materia de una negociación de un régimen
nuevo internacional
el control de drogas de fiscalización de
drogas y eso lo veo muy lejos y no creo
que el gobierno de colombia tenga un
clara la ruta para llegar hasta allá un
agradecimiento para usted a usted y en
otras noticias a echarle cristo un
congresista demócrata de 66 años que en
el pasado fue republicano y que bajó los
conservadores gobierno del estado de
florida hace más de una década será el
oponente del actual gobernador o ron de
santis en las elecciones de noviembre
nuestro corresponsal en miami alto nivel
si nos explicó cómo se prevé la
contienda
pues sí la verdad es que ahora se espera
una contienda aún más reñida entre
charlie crist y el actual gobernador de
florida ron de sant y es lo que se
espera ahora es que charlie crist pueda
también movilizar tanto el voto
demócrata como también el voto de los
republicanos más moderados y que no se
pueden sentir a gusto con la línea dura
de la política de ron de sant y es que
en los últimos tiempos ha estado
promoviendo políticas pues como la ley
antiaborto también la ley antiinmigrante
o incluso esas polémicas medidas para
prohibir hablar sobre identidad sexual
en las escuelas pero también estas
elecciones aquí en florida deben servir
también para analizar de qué pasará de
aquí a dos años y florida acaba siendo
un estado péndulo o si finalmente acaba
reafirmándose por un estado
completamente republicano como lo vimos
dos años en estas elecciones
presidenciales
los servidores públicos venezolanos
protestaron para exigir un salario digno
y la derogación de las regulaciones
gubernamentales que según dicen han
reducido sus ingresos en un 40% a la
manifestación también se sumaron
jubilados y estudiantes que se
movilizaron desde el ministerio de
educación hasta el centro de caracas los
jóvenes también reclamaron mejores becas
la inflación anual este año hasta julio
alcanzó el 137 por ciento según datos
extraoficiales ya que el banco de
venezuela no ha divulgado cifras
oficiales de inflación
[Música]
y la vice presidenta argentina cristina
fernández de kirchner se defendió de las
acusaciones de corrupción en su contra
por las que la fiscalía pide para ella
12 años de prisión la ex mandataria
aseguró que los argumentos relacionados
con obras públicas eran falsos fuera de
la casa de la líder se agolparon en
cientos de personas que hicieron una
calle de honor que la siguió hasta el
congreso donde se encuentra su oficina y
allí grabó el vídeo de rechazo
en chaco las hasta aquí el informativo
siga con nosotros
[Música]